hallo wenn ihr wissen wollt wie man
diesen pinguin aus modelliermasse
herstellt dann bleibt jetzt dran
die blüten passen und die modelliermasse
da muss die ganze zeit über luftdicht
verpackt sein
das heißt auch wenn er damit arbeitet
nehmt ihr die teile die nicht
verarbeitet unter einem teller und
schüsseln und natürlich in tüten
verpackt das erste was er immer machen
müsst ist die masse weich zu kneten
maria püschel hände einfetten
für den pinguin brauchen wir jetzt
schwarze orangefarbene und weiße modell
ihr passte und die schwarze habe ich
jetzt schon vorbereitet und hier zeige
ich euch wie ich diese masse auch roche
einfärben zum einfärben zieht ihr euch
am besten einweg handschuhe an
denn die farben drehen sonst in eure
fingernägel ein und die gehen zwar recht
gut wieder raus aber so habe die saubere
hände zu färben nehme ich die wirkung
covers und hier habe ich auch noch eine
andere marke squires kitchen nennen die
sich und aus den drei farben mache ich
jetzt einen orange ich bin uns aber
jetzt nicht komplett das ganze weiß
sondern nur die hälfte und in anderen
teil habe ich jetzt wieder ein
ich habe sie einen gelb ton hier ein
brot und hier ein etwas leichteres
skodas mails orange geht und aus den
farben müsst ihr euch jetzt das passende
orange und benutzt am anfang immer wenig
farbe
und benutzt auch immer einen frischen
löffel bei jeder anderen farbe
jetzt beginne ich mit dem pinguin k dazu
braucht ihr natürlich die schwarz aus
drei frauen die jetzt eine kugel
entweder macht ihr das auf eure
arbeitsfläche indem ihr eure hand etwas
kugelförmig formt und die kugel hin und
her gleiten last oder ihr macht es
einfach zwischen den helden diesen
beiden formen dir dann etwas kegelförmig
zwischen euren händen
einen ziemlich langen kopf und einen
dicken körper
praktisch so
dann nehmt ihr euch eine scheibe und
schneidet die flügel ein
dann müsste jetzt darauf achten dass sie
nicht zu tief einschneiden sonst geht es
ja hier in den körper mit rein
also lieber etwas weniger am anfang wenn
man hier einmal hier und den rest kommt
jetzt mit den händen aus also geht mit
den fingern unter den flügel trägt den
etwas flach und zieht ihn in die länge
und hier müsst ihr die spuren der
sheriff erwischen und glatt streichen
und auf der anderen seite genauso den
flügel etwas dünner machen und in die
länge ziehen und ihr könnt ihr auch so
lange machen wie ihr wollt
dann nehmen wir euch die weiße blüten
passte oder modelliermasse das war nur
ein kleines stück vom sie auch zu einer
kugel diese so etwas oval zu geformt
werden und dann drückt ihr das platz das
geht ganz gut zwischen den finger
kann jetzt nämlich etwas zucker kleber
oder wasser ich zeige euch am ende des
videos wie ich superkleber herstelle
pinsel damit den bauch ein und stand
drückt ihr den weißen bauch da dran und
auch schön an den rändern dass die nicht
abstehen
nehmen wir dann wieder weiße blüten
passte vor sie zu einer kugel und
halbiert sie so entstehen etwa zwei
gleich große teile und die form der so
eine jeweils einer kugel und das ergeben
dann die augen
diese kugeln geformt jetzt etwas so war
für mich mit einem leichten druck dann
drückt der sie platz und schaut ob sie
von der größe her passen
ich mache mir jetzt noch einen tick
kleiner
könnt ihr sie mit zucker kleber auf das
gesicht kleben
die orangefarbene blüten pastor wollt
ihr auch zu einer kugel und reich wird
sie das werden jetzt die füße die rollt
ihr wieder zu kugeln die kugeln rollte
dann zu einem tropfen und zwar mit einem
leichten fingerdruck auf die eine seite
kontrolliert auch dass sie gleich groß
sind
diese drückt der dann flach
dann nehmt ihr euch ein messer oder wie
ich so einen kater und setzt hier die 10
und das geht am besten so von vorne nach
hinten
bis 23
da kommt dann etwas zucker kleber drauf
stellt die füße dann direkt
nebeneinander und setzt euren pinguin
jetzt da
als nächstes kommen die dann den
schnabel dazu widersprachen blüten
passte oder modelliermasse die drückt
ihr etwas flach und schneidet oder
schiebt sie in eine dreieckige form
könnte auch etwas mit den fingern formen
dann hebt es mal an euren pinguin dran
und schaut wie groß ein schnabel werden
muss und dann schneidet ihr da hinten
ein gerades stück ab ruhig auch mal dran
heben
bei mir passt und superkleber dran
diesmal aber an den schnabel und stand
den schnabel hier antreten wenn ihr
möchtet nehmt ihr euch einen zahnstocher
oder eben so ein modell wie er starb und
schlecht da noch zwei kleine löcher in
die nasenlöcher und jetzt werden nur
noch die pupillen die könnte jetzt mit
schwarzer modelliermasse draufkleben
oder mit einem schwarzen lebensmittel
stift drauf male zum drauf malen sollte
die masse aber erstmal etwas an trocknen
wer möchte kann den pinguinen jetzt noch
eine weihnachtsmütze aufsatz für die
weihnachts mitzunehmen ich mir jetzt
etwas roten rote modelliermasse die für
mich zu einer kugel und dann so eine
fehde
und da geht jetzt mit der spitze des
pinsels mit der rückseite hier rein
mache ein loch und durch kreisende
bewegungen weite ich das noch aus und
falls ihr da vielleicht zu einem
whirlpool habt geht das auch mit dem
ganz gut
minute dann die gewünschte größe
erreicht habt schneidet ihr am besten
diesen rand sauber ab danach braucht ihr
wieder weiße blüten passte und rollt
diese aus dann schneide ich mir dann ein
stück zu recht mit hilfe des linearen
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch so eine
spritztour eures spritzbeutel und
schlechte hier rein und so entsteht an
dieser preiseffekt
und klebt sie mit etwas kleber fest
und den überschuss schneidig mit dem
kater oder mit einem messer weg und auf
den resten für mich eine kugel die kommt
dann nämlich oben drauf und die folgt
ihr auch noch etwas mit diesem mit
dieser spritztour
da mache ich jetzt wieder eine kleine
ein kleines loch rhein mit der spitze
meines pinsels da kommt kleber rein und
damit die kugel einfach darauf gesteckt
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr dann die
mit eurem pinguin aufsetzen
für den zucker kleber nehmt ihr euch
etwas 60 milliliter abgekochtes wasser
das ist jetzt noch ganz heiß und da
kommt jetzt ein teelöffel von diesem cmc
rein
das macht ihr am besten in so einem
schraubglas verschließt den deckel und
schüttelte schuss du hast du aber auch
manchmal läuft es aus und da bilden sich
klümpchen aber die lösen sich dann über
nacht
also lass dir das an einer nacht stehen
und am nächsten tag sieht dann der
kleber so aus ist ziemlich dickflüssig
und da könnt ihr euch dann immer die
menge rausnehmen die ihr braucht und
geht da auch auf keinen fall mit einem
pinsel oder mit einem dreckigen
löffelrein zumindest fängt der kleber
und zu schicken und im kühlschrank hält
das sich etwa vier bis sechs wochen